who are these conspiracy theorists that
uh the ceo of pfizer and the head of the
world economic are talking about well
it's people like dr robert malone
uh who actually owns more patents on the
mrna technology than anyone he was
basically the founder of mrna technology
and of course you guys remember dr
robert malone because he went on joe
rogan to say that this vaccine was
completely out of control and that these
organizations are evil etc etc and then
what happened well the episode got taken
down he got kicked off twitter for three
days everyone ran around saying joe
rogan was racist well dr robert malone
just testified to the texas senate about
the great reset and what these people
are doing this is just a couple days ago
what i believed for a long time had to
be a crazy conspiracy theory
this great reset
um that was a book title published by
the head of the world economic forum
four months into the outbreak
that spoke specifically about exploiting
the outbreak for other purposes having
to do with an economic agenda
in fact we should take that seriously
that appears to have been the case it
appears to have been
whether you know all the nuance of
where did the virus come from how is it
generated was it intentionally released
was it inadvertently released all that
stuff is unanswerable
but i believe that when you look at the
data
the information about the policies when
they were implemented
the monetary policies that were
implemented that we're now living with
the consequences of
those data can best be fit as consistent
with
the plans of
um a group
of people who had strong economic
interests
and it's very difficult for me to
account for the policies that have been
added so last question okay so there's
the guy who basically invented the mrna
technology there's the guy who went on
joe rogan just to express his views
about the vaccines and mandates and
everything else he was kicked off
twitter you all remember this he was
kicked off twitter and then remember we
had that week where everyone was talking
about d-platforming joe rogan and
spotify was going to get rid of him and
people were talking about how he's
racist and needs to be censored and then
magically out of nowhere this video of
him saying the n-word appeared even
though he wasn't saying in a pejorative
way you could see how the machine
operates does robert malone strike you
as an alarmist or a conspiracy theorist
or anything else or is he laying out
he's going boy you know guys there's
this book by the by this guy and in the
book they talk about how we're going to
do this great reset and we can very
obviously see how that is connected to
covet and he speaks in a very very calm
manner